un vaste chantier sur tout un étage
d'immeuble encore quelques couches de
peinture et kimberley clark pourra
terminer l'aménagement
on est au bord de l'autoroute
métropolitaine dans le quartier saint
michel c'est là que les ateliers 33,33
de marc séguin sont en train de voir le
jour sans les papiers et cartons
ou
à terme ils veulent accueillir près
d'une centaine de créateurs dans tout
l'immeuble
les cas d'artistes qui perdent leurs
locaux se sont multipliées avec la
flambée de nous lui le cas du 305
bellechasse par exemple ou de l'édifice
cadbury
aujourd'hui c'est une jeune coopérative
qui s'apprête à quitter ce bâtiment de
la rue masson mais parce qu'elle va
devenir propriétaire juste à côté car le
ram est vraiment on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de chance un projet qui va très
très vite en fait comparativement à ce
qu'on nous avait dit au départ
peu de temps après que madly l'artiste
ébéniste fut fondé sa coopérative qui va
qui est montréal ont mis la main à la
poche je vous annonce que le
gouvernement du québec investit 25
millions de dollars et montréal a ajouté
5 millions tout en précisant le
programme d'aujourd'hui n'est pas par
exemple pourrait acheter un bâtiment et
pourtant huit mois plus tard valérie
plantes visite la coopérative d'artistes
ça a permis
et notamment près d'un demi million de
dollars pour parvenir à ceux ci sont
prévus en deux mois de plus pour faire
l'acquisition une offre d'achat sur un
bâtiment en 90 % de la facture des
rénovations sera couverte par la
subvention une aide pour pallier les
effets de l'embourgeoisement demandé un
propriétaire privé tu peux pas m'entêter
loyer je n'ai pas cette possibilité là
par contre comme ville j'ai la
possibilité de soutenir tu sais pas je
donner de l'argent pour le loyer c'est
vraiment leur donner de l'accompagnement
pour qu'elles s'organisent et faire une
cohue et acheter un bel des housses
financé à hauteur de 5 millions la
transformation du 33,33 crémazie
celui-la ressources inespérées qui a
guidé la petite clope à travers les
méandres administratifs ce qui est bien
avec ce genre de projet là c'est que les
lakhouad madame va avoir le couteau au
niveau des augmentations de loyer seront
pas attendre un propriétaire de ont fait
de rebuy d'airness que je vais être
renouvelée c'est quoi l'augmentation que
je vais subir une crainte omniprésente
dans le milieu ici on est dans les
ateliers cassegrain on est un groupe ii
à peu près quinze artistes nettement
puis comme vous voyez aller humeur qu'on
a construit phase 1 ils ont la garantie
de rester locataire 25 ans d'un
propriétaire qui bénéficie d'un
incitatif pour que ça soit avantageux on
a besoin de la ville on a besoin d
arrondissement qui permettent aux
propriétaires
d'avoir droit des dérogations par
exemple comme celle de pouvoir louer une
plus grande surface sont contraintes
réglementaires quant à la hausse
continue de la valeur foncière au niveau
des taxes on rembourse jusqu'à 20% à
concurrence de 130000 sont deux
exercices financiers les taxes foncières
donc en plus de soutenir l'acquisition
et la rénovation en soutien les
premières années où on est conscient que
ça va le fait de rénover ou d'acquérir
augmente la taxe
c'est la faiblesse du programme selon
catherine bodmer malheureusement après
ces deux ans on en a on est très inquiet
en fait de voir après avoir tout
aménager ces espaces là les taxes
augmentent et comment ça va jouer sur
les loyers au final donc c'est un peu le
paradoxe qui existe ou la ville veut
soutenir la pérennisation des ateliers
pierre même temps dépend complètement
des taxes les artistes montréalais
doivent en tout cas faire preuve de
créativité pour continuer que ce soit en
s'excentrant dans le quartier chabanel
pour certains au bord de l'autoroute
pour d'autres ou en réussissant à rester
au coeur de la ville
[Musique]